j'ai pas cyril est ce que vous avez un
paquet de mouchoirs oui j'en ai toujours
sur moi d'accord merci parce que je suis
à deux doigts de pleurer en écoutant
raquel garrido parce que vraiment ce
registre m'a bouleversé on a
l'impression que jean luc mélenchon et
ses amis c'est nelson mandela malcom x
je les vois en train de lever le poing à
bobigny pour un processus du cinéma
c'est du spectacle
et moi j'en ai ras-le-bol de ces
personnes qui lorsque et eric le dit
très bien lorsque c'est dans l'autre
camp réclame des têtes à tout va tout le
monde a voulu se tait à juste titre sur
françois fillon moi le premier j'ai été
choqué et dès lors que ça les touche
maintenant on est des victimes
j'en ai un peu ras le bol de ces
politiques qui en font de leur vie un
métier et jean luc mélenchon j'aimerais
rappeler
moi je suis en 1987 il était déjà élu
cet homme s'est enrichi grâce à la vie
politique
cet homme a été battu à l'élection
présidentielle et on le voit
perpétuellement en train de revenir et
de pleurnicher et la république c'est
moi
6 à 2 c'est insupportable c'est une
phrase c'est une phrase qui est
insupportable pour vous la république
c'est murray plus que c'est moi c'est
jean luc mélenchon il fait partie de la
république mais de la même chose que moi
moi j'aimerais appeler une petite
histoire aussi avec le distribuer si
nous avions eu le même comportement face
aux policiers hors caméra on aurait pris
facilement de la garde à vue sans
problème j'aimerais rappeler je sais pas
si les gens se souviennent il ya un
jeune noir à sevran qui s'est fait
interpellé par des policiers ils ont
fait une prise de catch poirier alors
qu'il a tenté de séparer les gens il
s'est retrouvé en garde avait
heureusement les réseaux sociaux ont
montré que ne l'était plus tôt victime
que coupable
donc c'est facile ensuite de pleurnicher
mois le quotidien des gens je le vois
honnêtement je pense que quand je
regarde un peu la réaction du public ils
ont vraiment rien à faire de mélenchon
parce que si le procès mélenchon bas
c'est son problème c'est pas que pour
l'année jean les problématiques des gens
c'est de trouver un emploi c'est d'avoir
un accès au logement c'est les
discriminations c'est les violences
faites aux femmes on va en parler lancé
le rider de métro non qu'il en fait trop
parce qu'il rapporte tout à sa propre
personne
mais sauf que les gens et non rien ils
n'ont rien à faire en revanche jean luc
mélenchon lors de la campagne point de
cette présidentielle a été un très bon
orateur il a réussi à cristalliser un
peu la galère du quotidien l'émergence
des gilets jaunes c'est un peu
l'ambiance mélenchon durant la campagne
sauf qui retombe dans ses travers et
quand je le vois comme ça je le trouvais
absolument insupportable et il est temps
qu'une page se tourne parce que là à mon
sens mélenchon c'est terminé
laissons la place à à d'autres
honnêtement alexis corbière je trouve
qu'il a un discours un peu plus
rationnel 1 puis je fais pas la leche
parce que vous êtes là rachel peu raquel
puisque vraiment voilà mais honnêtement
je trouve un peu plus terre à terre il
ya des personnes qui émergent mais à mon
sens il est discrédité dans le paysage
politique et dans les paysans chimiques
sur les conversions de penser qu'il est
discrédité les gens honnêtes m'en irai
il ya toujours des sympathisants là
c'est trop il faut que ça s'arrête il
faut qu'une page se tourne